Falcon is pushing down range
with the incredible views that we've
been seeing you can see that Falcon 9
has lifted off from pad 39a carrying our
starlink payload into space
and we are throttling down the engines
in preparation for Max Q
Max Q is the supersonic
Max Q is the largest structural load
that the vehicle will see on ascent
[Music]
Max Q
[Music]
there's that call out that we have
passed through Max Q
now next up we do have four events
happening that will be Mikko stage
separation scs-1 and then fairing
deployment
Mikko is main engine cut off and that's
where all nine of those engines that you
see right now lit up on the first stage
those will shut down and help slow the
stage down in preparation for stage
separation
that will be when the first stage
separates from the second stage first
stage will make its way back down to
earth and land on our drone ship just
read the instructions today
and the second stage will continue with
ses1 or second stage engine start one
that's where we light up that mbec
engine on the second stage and then
shortly after we will deploy the fairing
halves
it's trajectory nominal
so far
trajectory is looking nominal and we are
coming up on those few events just a few
seconds
stage separation confirmed
thanks
bearing separation confirmed
as you may have just seen we had Mikko
stage separation ses1 that mvac engine
on your right hand screen lit up and we
had fairing deployment
the fairing halves will be making their
way back down to earth and we will be
attempting to recover them with our
recovery vessel dug today
on your left hand screen you can see the
first stage you can see that the grid
fins on the first stage have
the grid fins on the first stage have
deployed
acquisition of signal Bermuda
both vehicles continue on nominal
trajectories
and great call outs there both vehicles
are looking nominal again first stage is
making its way back down to earth while
the second stage still has the Starling
payload attached to it carrying it to
its targeted drop-off orbit
now coming up next for the first stage
is the entry burn
that entry burn will be where three of
nine m1d engines reignite on the vehicle
this helps slow the stage down as it
re-enters into the Earth's atmosphere
after the entry burn will be a final
burn that will be the landing burn on
the first stage it's just a single
engine burn
the center E9 engine that helps slow the
stage down as just before it touches
down for landing
each one of our m1d engines have about
190 000 pounds of thrust at sea level
and this is just enough thrust to help
slow the stage down just in time for
landing
now the entry burn that I mentioned is
just under two minutes away on the first
stage
but if you look at your right hand
screen we do have some awesome views
there
incredible view with the Earth in the
background and the sun in the background
there
on your left hand screen is a view of
the first stage again the grid fins are
deployed this helps to steer the vehicle
as it makes its way back to its Landing
Zone
there are four Hypersonic grid fins
just
between the inner stage and the top of
the first stage vehicle
again these help guide the vehicle to
Landing Zone
you also may see some bursts of nitrogen
gas there that helps with Attitude
control on the first stage
and we are just about 30 seconds away
from
the entry burn on the first stage
stage one FTS has saved
page one entry burn startup
as you can see the engines have
reignited on the first stage
page one entry burn shutdown
and with that the engine shutting down
that conclusive entry nominal
includes the entry burn on the first
stage and today's Mission Mark spacex's
197th overall launch to FTS has saved
and as mentioned previously it's the
15th flight for this first stage booster
having previously launched 14 missions
and breaking a new record flight for for
flight proven boosters
are about 45 seconds away from The
Landing burn beginning on the first
stage
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet consolation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide high
speeds to your terminal guidance
high-speed low latency internet to
people living in remote and Rural
locations around the globe
Landing burn come coming up here in
just under 10 seconds
stage one Landing burn
and there you can see that engine has
ignited let's watch as Falcon 9 touches
down on just read the instructions
and there you can see that Falcon 9 has
touched down for its 15th Landing for
this booster this marks our 58th Landing
this year signal Newfoundland and 158th
overall Landing of an orbital class
rocket
we also heard a call out for Seco that
is second engine cutoff one and we heard
a confirmation of good orbit
and there you can see that mvac engine
has shut down loss of signal cape
and stage two is now carrying 54
Starling satellites into low earth orbit
thanks for joining us today you can
check social media for confirmation of
payload deploy and we'll see you again
next time